and a cotillion oh you guys began French
was it hard to say goodbye to him it was
it was you know we're an unlikely
friendship me in the wolf from Twilight
would say before I reminisce about Andy
is brilliant and she's great fun and
she's very funny but it was odd saying
goodbye to him I've told you the my my
sister's gonna be very angry with me for
this no I am Telling You so my sister
when the Twilight films were out it was
like a lot of people of a certain age I
think when the Twilight films came out
in that she developed her sexual
fantasies for a vampire and or a wolf
when she found out that Taylor was on
the show she was so overexcited but she
had two young children so she could
never across three series she could
never come and meet him and I realized
when when they said that Andy was taken
over that she was never going to meet
him and I thought that's a shame for her
fantasies not to be fulfilled yeah so I
facetimed from the set I told Taylor to
get ready that he was standing out shot
and she we have a Davis family rule if
someone rings in the day it means
someone's died you know what's wrong and
I wait so I separate things fine oh good
okay cuz what you want and I said well a
little surprise for you who's this and I
went and Taylor went hey Sean and my
sister went yep hello you could see his
face when he went are you okay yep fine
thank you I'm great yeah I'm great and I
went and he went I'm gonna go back on to
say okay good wait till he gone I rang
her back and I'll miss my Greg I was
having a poo
[Applause]
sorry to the phone when you humming one
dying it's not like someone had
[Music]